do you have any idea what's going on
right now in the world of Economics am I
the only one here that's thinking what
is going on today I'm proud to say that
under the UK's presidency the G7 is
launching a set of public policy
principles for retail Central Bank
digital currencies cbdc's critics Point
know that such a system would give the
state full access to the details of all
transactions as well as the ability to
cut off an individual's money supply
with the flick of a digital switch it
creates a far more efficient way to
discriminate against certain people you
don't need that middleman anymore again
with a click of a button if you're not a
good citizen your money will be
programmed to be used against you we're
looking at a politician here it has a
lot more direct exposure to the crypto
industry than say most world leaders
it's much easier to push forward
political agendas and political
ideologies when you have money which is
programmable with just a click of a
button Rishi sunak who is our new prime
minister plans on basically abolishing
money he wants to have a cryptocurrency
that is state-backed so that all money
can run through this cryptocurrency
Bitcoin which is backed by the state now
if this happens if there is a
cryptocurrency coin
which is backed by the government am I
the only one that's thinking well that
is gonna literally just replace
everything it's even happening now when
I go and buy things now it's very
difficult if you have cash when it used
to buy ice cream from an ice cream van
it would be like old cash only now it's
anything but cash I believe that cash is
going to become extended and it already
is it's already happening you just can't
use it anymore it's becoming worthless
and I think that when britcoin or
whatever it is comes in place it's gonna
absolutely override every other type of
currency there is they're going to
slowly say we don't accept that we don't
accept this we don't accept the other we
only accept Bitcoin which is backed by
the states and the reason I think that
is because number one the way the media
are talking about this britcoin and
these Central Bank digital currency like
it's the best thing since sliced bread
is a red flag for me observe the masses
and do the opposite listen to what the
media is saying I always like to think
the opposite the media you're talking
about oh don't buy property property is
a terrible investment I'm thinking okay
I'm gonna buy some houses if you Google
Rishi sunak
cbdc that's that stands for Central Bank
digitalized currency look man top comes
up is report just this is on digital.fyi
cbdc transactions to surpass 177 billion
globally by when 2030. why Bitcoin bring
legitimacy to cryptocurrency in the UK
it's all positive every media article is
talking about this and it's a wonderful
thing CNBC say Rishi sees the
opportunity and potential that crypto
has and wants the UK to be a leader in
it oh give me a break will you be so
positive media Outlets BBC about me when
I launch my own bank to help the Common
Man by the way Leeds bank is coming
watch this space we are at our very last
stages of regulations with my lawyers
right now will you be so positive of
course not
let me tell you something really
interesting okay when cryptocurrency
first became a thing with Bitcoin all
the coins I'm thinking did the
government see it and think Mmm this is
a threat to us we need to come in and
take this and regulate it or
did they start in the first place as a
test
everyone gets excited or crypto really
good we all like we get used to the idea
and then bang they bring in their own
version and it's digitalized and we have
to use that version and now it's like oh
use brickcoin to pay for this you can
buy your own screen with Bitcoin you can
buy your Chanel handbag with britcoin
but cash they're already looking funny
they're gonna ban it they're going to
ban cash everything's gonna be crypto
everything's going to be through the
government why two big reasons and this
is the scary bit the first reason is
because it means that they have complete
control and power over everybody it's
even more controlled than when you have
a bank because if you've got Banks and
you're doing and you're doing transfers
you could have this bank that bank small
independent banks no no this is one
digital
cryptocurrency and if they don't like
you if they think you know what this
person put a post on social media which
we don't like what can they do
they can just close your account down
error oh great now what do I have to do
delete this tweet do this it's complete
power and also from a tax perspective is
why it's money right they're probably
annoyed the government that they're not
getting a slice of the pie every which
way now I'm not advocating that you
should not pay your taxes but right now
if you're taking cash and you're not
claiming it you shouldn't do that but if
you are doing that they don't know they
can't do anything about it so they want
all of the money they want all of the
Power so I am personally dubious I don't
like the idea I'm in the good side You
could argue that it's good you could say
that wow it's going to be really easy to
trace
um cryptocurrency is great it is fast
and they're just making sure that it's
safe and criminals can't you know abuse
it yeah I understand that but I think
it's about money I think it's about
power I think it's about control and I
think that Rishi is being used to be the
advocate of it and I believe that it's
happening in this decade before 2030 and
I think that they're going to completely
ban cash that's my prediction action
what do I think you should do about this
apart from just thinking well that's
pretty scary well I guess there's a few
things you can do number one you need to
be able to make a lot of money cool but
number two is you need to be able to
make a lot of money whereby you can
actually keep that money whether that's
in form of cryptocurrency whether it's
Bitcoin or Bitcoin whether it's in Gold
Silver and property or in your bank you
need to structure your wealth in such a
way whereby you can own it and it can't
get taken from you rather than being
annoyed at the rich and powerful and
thinking ah usually thinking how can I
become rich and Powerful too that's what
I've done my whole life as an adult it's
been okay rich and Powerful I'm going to
become rich and Powerful too but then
when I become rich and Powerful rather
than being a jerk rather than trying to
take everything away from everybody so I
can have everything I'm thinking how can
I now be generous how can I pull people
up how can I be inspiration how can I be
a light so follow the money become rich
and Powerful yourself and then help
people I mean another thing is this we
should not be standing for this whole
someone said something I don't like
therefore
send them to prison take away their Bank
cancel their life like this whole
culture is just completely wrong now I'm
all for accountability actions have
consequences if you break the law and
you're hurting people wrong then you
should be punished maybe you should go
to prison I'm all for that what I'm not
for is someone saying something that's
deemed a little bit unpolitically
correct or a little bit offensive and
then mob culture just taking everything
from them making their life a misery the
government closing down their bank
account that I'm not for and that's why
I was so pleased recently with Gary
lineker when he I don't even see what
his tweet was but I did see the BBC
trying to cancel him and then I saw
everybody supporting Gary lineker and
saying nah man and all the commentators
were like if you cancel him we're not
going to either and I was like yes when
you see someone being treated unfairly
by the government or by the media being
canceled I think I think the key is to
just speak up because when enough of us
speak up and say that's wrong that's not
right they have to ultimately listen so
in conclusion I do think cash is going
to become extinct I do think Rishi is
going to Pioneer a global potentially
cryptocurrency which is backed by the
state it is scary they are going to have
control they are they already do to a
point where they're going to have
complete control so the key is be smart
educate yourself don't stand up for
people for the media telling lies or
ridiculing people because of an
offensive tweet stand up for people like
Gary lineker and also ultimately today's
got enough problems there's no point
stressing they're being depressed about
what potentially could happen in a few
years time the key is to enjoy every day
to its Max but make sure you're creating
as much wealth as you can and in a way
where that wealth is protected and
that's what this channel is for I hope
you enjoyed the video see you next time
thank you
foreign